this morning on the dish a man credited
with revolutionizing Scandinavian
cuisine growing up in the 60s
Klaus Meyer says food and his native
Denmark was often frozen canned and
tasteless later working in France he
fell in love with great cooking and
wanted to bring it home in 2003 he
co-founded Copenhagen's Noma voted best
restaurant in the world four times now
he's come to America with the Great
Northern food hall and the
michelin-starred egg earn both in New
York's Grand Central Terminal
Klaus Meyer we are thrilled to have you
here thanks thanks for coming tell us
what's on this table to start well
starting down there you have a beet root
ATAR with the horseradish cream you have
gravlax your Luck's you have beautifully
boiled the fingerling potatoes you have
roasted dark packed with prunes and
apples you have a beautiful gastrique
based sauce caramelized potatoes braised
red cabbage and reseller mound with
sherry sauce some honey hearts to begin
with and a mold cider is that right yeah
I have to go back to this line frozen
canned and tasteless was how you
describe food growing up and yeah and
packed with trans fatty acids
retro-styled bread crumbs he was
horrible I mean this was the darkest
period of Danish food history and also
my mother absolutely didn't want to cook
so how did you what lit the fire for you
I think it was the the discrepancy
between this 19 years lived in a
culinary darkness in Denmark and then
one year bathed in light in Gascony
France and where did you take that once
you had that light where did you go from
there well fired up by that light and
and and also I come from a divorced
family where my mother became an
alcoholic my father left the building so
exposed to love and amazing food in
getting a job France
I've got like almost like a calling and
I wanted to go home to my my native
country to change food basically to
restore love in the families when you
when you tried to change things
initially what was the reaction I mean
the first 20 years I I did it like an
entrepreneur I
kind of moly single-handed he tried to
repair on the imperfections I stumbled
across without too much of an impact
then with I decided to take a top a
top-down approach in 2003 now and the
idea was to kind of try to build a
movement around this Nordic cuisine
ideology we asked ourselves the question
if in this food test that we are going
to create one of the greatest food
cutters in the world
what is that we're bringing through the
plate what we're bringing to the table
what we doing for the world and then we
decided to create a restaurant that
would live out this philosophy in the
most extreme way very ambitious yeah
yeah and of course everybody didn't get
it in the first second but the point was
not to win over every single individual
in Denmark in a week but to win over the
most important stakeholders so we we
managed to unboard government research
institutions big food companies and and
basically slowly build momentum and and
it was difficult to be against the
Nordic cuisine movement you talk about
that movement but it's also been about
social change for you too as a well
coming from from this childhood I always
wanted to try to be somebody who would
help people in need I just didn't
exactly know how to do it in a smart way
but in 2010 I I found the melting pot
Foundation which became my my vehicle
for bringing crucial resources to
struggling neighborhoods ultimately what
brought you to New York
well III learned about the opportunity
to open a restaurant at a food hall in
in the iconic Grand Central Terminal and
I couldn't get it out of my head and
also I have four women around me I mean
four four girls three daughters and a
wife who are deeply in love with New
York City and it is the greatest city in
the world as we all know so I mean there
was no way to not to do it well we're
glad they're in love with New York City
glad you came that's right as we have
you signed the dish I'll ask you if you
could have a meal with anyone Castro
present who would it be
I mean Barack Obama would be high on my
list and so would Martin Luther King
that's a very good less yeah we like
that chef Klaus Meyer thank you so much
for joining us thank you Amy and for
more on Chef Meyer and the dish you can
head to our website at
this morning calm